it's from the New York Post Elon Musk
Snipes Zuck is a cuck about metaboss
Zuckerberg after rival rival Twitter app
launch so threads has cracked 100
million users uh I still think it's not
that good and I'm I'm I don't know if
it'll actually take over but uh Elon
Musk called Mark Zuckerberg a cuck
okay he then uh actually went on
to call for a literal dick measuring
contest between him and uh Mark
Zuckerberg and then did Mark respond
with somebody get my microscope is that
what he said I saw a picture that said
that I don't know if that was doctored
or if that was about it so get my
microscope did they include that in this
so uh in the four days blah blah
musk tweeted responding then Wendy said
you should go to space to make him mad
and that was it some people were
appalled by musk's tweet I was surprised
that you know he tweeted that he wanted
to have a dick measuring contest and a
bunch of people were like you forgot to
post this from your parody Twitter
account you posted it accidentally on
your main
yeah do you think he runs his parody
Twitter account that's my favorite
conspiracy theory is behind his own
Verity account good idea yeah controlled
that position you know
uh I do you guys are you on threads do
you guys like it yeah you maybe Ian can
answer this is there any truthy idea
that they hired a bunch of people from
from Twitter
I can't verify it but yeah Facebook
denies it Facebook tonight get out of
here what rights does Elon Musk have if
that's the case well they did I don't
know actually that's a good question
um Trade Secrets like if you quit one
place you probably are under some sort
of NDA that you can't talk about the
code that you wrote at that place but
you can you might know ways to recreate
the system without the exact coding you
might be able to change some of the
coding so like but that's the problem
with proprietary code in general and
companies owning code is is when they
leave the company
they like the company doesn't really own
the code it's the people that make the
code that on the code so that's why I'm
a big advocate of freeing it
um
I wanted to I'm looking up if see if
Zuckerberg responded to Elon well he
wanted to have a dick measuring contest
yeah a literal one
I I don't see how that could have been
from a parody like they actually tweeted
that so this is our this is our current
state of discourse the big thing with
threads is that it is um it's not good
and I don't know what else to say about
it Instagram is just not a place for
high level conversations so it's like
Facebook is you know what is Facebook a
phone book a directory Twitter is our
news it's it's it's basically the like
the news networks back in the day people
would go on debate the news on the news
show if you went to The Simpsons for
your news you're not really getting news
and this is basically what threads is
threads is in like Instagram's an
entertainment platform not a serious
political platform it does have Politics
on it but it's not that serious and so
the platform just I just you know I
think it's more likely to happen young
people on Instagram will switch to
Twitter once they start getting more
politically active
it's not not going to be a switch to
threads or some other stupid app or
something do you think the people I know
who are like in content creation who
don't like Twitter but like Instagram
tend to be not political at all they're
you know Fitness people they're they
have cookbooks they do you know things
outside of this uh do you think that
there's any chance that thread basically
becomes a Twitter for those people no
what do they have to talk about I don't
know but people like them people follow
their content I assume it's the same
thing with anywhere they have questions
we're releasing this thing if I'm
following a guy because he does
backflips off of buildings why do I care
when he when he makes a post with no
picture of a backflip and he just says
something like went to Wendy's today so
I'm like show me a backflip or otherwise
Instagram's the platform where you'll
see a video of him doing the backflip
where it says went to Wendy's today over
top of the image or the video they don't
do just text is this meta Zuckerberg
he's good at like copying other people
and compiling stuff like um
Facebook was just like Friendster more
or less uh he kind of ripped the concept
of Myspace it was like a developed
version of that and then they bought
Instagram he didn't build that himself
they they they bought Oculus I think
they had the Oculus come in now they
have that and now they're doing this
they basically got the developers from
Twitter to recreate trying to recreate
Twitter so but then you know it's not
really an argument that he's bad at what
he does it's just not
it's not super original it's kind of
kind of lame but it's functional it's
just not creative he's not the most
sorry Mark do you think before markets
saturated on social media platforms
because you're I mean you do this for a
living you must have Instagram Facebook
Twitter like at what point is it too
many yeah I was gonna say I'm I'm a lot
I hate social media but I feel like
every month they're like launching a new
platform and it's really annoying I I'm
not on threads I'm not really even on on
truth I'm not really even on getter the
only one I really do because I think you
get the most bang for your buck is is
Twitter because I think that then can
also get aggregated or like disseminated
on to other platforms but yeah I don't I
don't think threads is gonna I don't I
mean because how could you maintain it
unless you really saw like like I'm
saying like if there was like threads
only had the mommy bloggers right and
that was where the mommy loggers went
for Twitter like maybe there would be
enough engagement there for your own
Niche Enclave of content for it to work
but Twitter already dominates this type
of media so how do you I mean gab and
other platforms exist but we have seen
that they do they haven't surpassed
Twitter yet at least why would threads
because it's already attached to
Instagram and people are already there
there's an access I just don't I don't
get it but I'm not a huge social media
to the old same censorship tricks of of
meta so it's like why would you want to
go backwards and go on a platform that
is certainly not going to let people
like us say what we want to say so
you're alienating like half the country
right there yeah at least half the world
it's how do you talk you can't talk
politics if there's a censorship Cloud I
mean you can't really effectively talk
about the possibilities you can't war
game your strategies and talk about what
horrible things might happen because if
the company's like no you can't even
mention that possibility like then I
can't have a conversation yeah that's
why I think it could only exist for
people who are non-political but then do
they have enough to talk about on them
no they don't really text I mean maybe
they do but not
like I did a review of this what did you
guys like I I just can't imagine it you
can post a video to Instagram already
you can post pictures what is somebody
who has dedicated themselves to a visual
medium gonna do with a written medium
that's why Twitter is news and politics
so all of these liberals and leftists
were like I'm going to Blue Sky I'm
going to Mastodon whatever they can it's
not going to change anything I would you
know they say they they added 100
million users and it's like why because
you have insta because your Instagram
and people just got a threads account
yeah that like come on of their billion
people other people who are already
using Instagram they just clicked a
button Twitter actually understands this
I think Elon and that's why they're
going so hard in the video now because
the the Twitter text is like the The
Rock Bottom you don't want to go that
direction if you have it you better have
it for your network I'm kind of
surprised YouTube doesn't have a better
messaging service
um they really drop the ball you guys at
Google with Google Plus and all that
crap just Consolidated into YouTube make
it the best social network but uh
Twitter's going full on long form video
videos subscription models audio
and that is that is absolutely the
future
do you think techs will ever come back
like is Twitter the space or for
transmitting data it's good for like uh
information but for communication it's
not very effective in my opinion but
it's that's true but it's faster than
video that's why it worked in an era of
video so someone can tweet something
like I am hungry and would like to have
a cheeseburger and then someone can
respond with cheeseburgers are unhealthy
you should consider a different option
and then you can respond with screw off
vegan you know a video back and forth is
not that easy to do but so like if
you're in text you're like we're gonna
get food uh later that's a good text but
if I'm like
how are you feeling about that in the
text oh did I do the wrong thing that is
not a text question that is no it is
insane inane if I ask you about emotions
in text I've missed like if you're like
if you want to tell me what you're going
to do I'm into it if I want to ask you
why that's text is not the place for
that in my opinion it gets starts to get
bogged down with what you think I mean
and what I mean there's a reason why
people aren't recording videos of
themselves to Twitter in response to
other people because text is the way to
do it it takes too long to load up and
watch and you gotta turn the volume up
you can read and see people can't absorb
in the middle of the night people can
read faster than they can watch a video
so people even say they'll Listen to Tim
cast IRL on two times speed which is
crazy because then I talk so fast as it
is but they'll do it because they can
understand it on Spotify you can do
three times three times speed
show done in 30 minutes if anybody gets
the transcript of this and reads it the
two-hour show yeah that would be insane
it would be nuts it's got a two two hour
show is it tens of thousands of words
every episode is a book and then you get
to hear the tone too you know the Tone's
like half the battle if not more 90 90
of communication is body language is
that true but so there's that bell curve
of
if you're so a book or something playing
audio probably makes sense short
conversations really annoying to listen
to you know I'm sorry I can't stand it
do not send me voice memos I will press
delete instantly I don't have two
minutes to listen to your thoughts when
I can read the whole thing in 10 seconds
it's just like I'll look at my uh we're
gonna mess up my phone on the look and
it'll show like the waveform like delete
or just leave a voicemail because then
there's at least the like attempted
transcription exactly right yeah yeah I
won't check my voicemail either yeah I
will read whatever I get sent and I'll
just delete text to me dude yeah text
really did revolutionize the way people
communicate instant instantly uh I don't
think voice memos can really compete
with them no but what does that have to
do with data transfer yeah
suffering no why me Elon Musk is calling
Zuckerberg
fighting that's my other question
where's this Coliseum fight that I was
promised I think in Rome at the Coliseum
are they doing it for sure I don't know
Lex Friedman's encouraging them not to
actually battle but just a spar and
become sparring partners for the good of
humanity because if they're get head
trauma I mean oh yeah I think it's a
duel you remember when uh um you know
Alexander Hamilton died in that duel
have another big moment so this is part
of culture they could bet their
companies and The Winner Takes all well
let's talk about consolidation the
winner is like but I don't want it
yeah
yeah the thing about the the old duels
it was that you know duels used to be
legit people would kill each other then
it went and became like an honor thing
where you wouldn't actually try to kill
the other guy it was about whether or
not you'd show up but it's kind of like
you know look and I guess with Hamilton
and Burr Hamilton was like yeah yeah
yeah and fight off to the side like we
get it we're here and then Burr was like
screw you and like actually he wanted to
kill him so he agreed to it his sacred
honor was intact as he died so uh and
then the young people were like this is
crazy why are you dueling we should stop
this that's the last duel in the United
States I don't think it was the last one
but dueling ultimately started to fade
out because young people thought it was
barbaric my thoughts on what elon's
doing is this is all publicity massive
publicity for Twitter and for meta right
now both those companies
none of this makes him look bad I think
I mean maybe this is like slightly
immature but you know ultimately he's
staying in everyone's heads he's still
thinking we're talking about like the
two two of the most influential
billionaires on Earth and they're just
having fun and playing around like
that's a good thing thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time